They acted like old college buddies.
These two men are - for many here - the pariahs
of this G20 summit.
President Vladimir Putin is in hot water over
Russia's seizure of Ukrainian ships after
a clash in the Black Sea.
Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman, meanwhile,
is accused of ordering the murder of dissident
Saudi journalist Jamal Khashoggi in Istanbul.
Saudi Arabia says the Crown Prince had no
role in it, the CIA says he did...
... and US President Donald Trump disagrees
with his own intelligence agency.
Trump denied talking with the man known as
MBS.
Reporter: "Mr President, what did you discuss
with MBS?"
Trump: "We had no discussion.
We had no discussion.
We might but we had none."
Earlier, at the traditional family photo,
the Crown Prince cut something of an isolated
figure.
Nobody wanting to shake his hand.
When it came to the clicking of cameras, Bin
Salman was on the edge of the frame.
France's Emmanuel Macron was later said to
have given him some firm words.
He can probably expect a few more by the end
of the summit.